hey guys it's Wednesday my name's Jeff
I'm Dan and you are watching GameSpot
years here's the things that happen to
gaming today
first up we've got a PSA if you've
installed the latest patch on ps4 for
Rainbow Six stage don't play it there
seems to be a pretty big error that
might cause your hard drive to become
corrupted don't worry Xbox one and PC
players so far those platforms appear to
be unaffected on ps4 though inviting
players to a party has led to system
crashes something heavy soft has advised
avoiding until a resolution is found it
might be safer to avoid playing the game
altogether though as several players
over on reddit have reported the error
corrupting their hard drive apparently
uninstalling the game and initializing
the system doesn't resolve the problem
Ubisoft is working with Sony on a
solution so I reckon it's probably best
to stay away from Rainbow six siege
until a fix for this one is announced
next up for tonight that game that's
going free-to-play next year but right
now you have to pay to play it currently
is getting a free-to-play mode this year
yeah the free part is a 100 player pvp
mode called fortnight battle royale
which will be available as a free
download on the Epic Games PC launcher
come September 26th the mode consists of
one giant map and a battle bus from
which you'll fall I'll play our unknowns
battlegrounds you'll employ your
building skills and shooting people in
the face skills in an attempt to be the
last one standing
all our battlegrounds it's fought it's
for now battle round we got ads
obviously matter another epic have
cleared up that they don't sell items
that give a competitive advantage within
the mode but at some point they will
sell things like cosmetics or compendium
like content for now fortnight's save
the world PvE campaign is still in paid
early access finally a Nintendo switch
version of Final Fantasy 15 might be on
the horizon oh speaking to Eurogamer
Final Fantasy 15 director Hajime Tabata
says his team is running tests to see if
the switch port is feasible saying we've
completed those tests and have worked
out where the ground lies we're
currently in the middle of the
discussion and debates about what we
should be doing and how to release that
on the switch
Tabata and his team appear to be
approaching the port with the right
attitude as he went on to say one thing
we value is to optimize the way the game
plays and the experience for the
individual Hardware it's on rather than
a one-size-fits-all
unfortunately no net was set for this
one as Tabata and Co are still in the
middle of discussions with Nintendo if
you're still hankering for more Final
Fantasy though Final Fantasy 9 is now
available on ps4 and Final Fantasy 50
means multiplayer expansion comrades is
out in just over a month on October 31st
that's everything we have for you today
enjoy the rest of your day and we'll see
you tomorrow and Friday for our top 5
news stories of the entire week we'll
see you guys like hey we're handed wife
walking dogs you know what am i cooking
it really good okay all right
y know we're getting a gesture do it
POSCO okay why did the left Mike make it
really good a wingman why this is great
at picking up hey come on yeah it's
pretty good I wouldn't make him a
terrible wingman yeah maybe